[Musique]
oui les bâtiments de demain vont changer
le vivre ensemble et c'est ce que je
veux vous dire très simplement en
essayant de vous faire partager
deux bonnes nouvelles la première c'est
que les bâtiments de demain sont déjà à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui la deuxième c'est
que ces bâtiments de demain vont
conduire à ce que notre façon de les
occuper de les habiter va transformer
notre façon d'être
il faut néanmoins avant que j'entre dans
le sujet que je tire au clair avec vous
une question qui devient agaçante que je
résume ainsi est ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire de faire tout ça est ce que
mettre des niveaux de performance
environnementale énergétique dans
l'ensemble de notre chaîne immobilière
vaut le coup je veux que vous partagiez
ma conviction qui est que nous n'avons
pas le choix et que la question que je
viens de poser ne doit plus se poser
nous n'avons pas le choix d'abord parce
que vous allez le voir dans un instant
les bâtiments de demain sont déjà en
chantier
mais surtout parce que lorsque l'on
observe un peu la situation de ces
bâtiments dans notre pays
ce sont de très gros pollueurs et qui
ont un score énergétiques et
environnementales tout à fait mauvais
sur le plan environnemental le quart des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
viennent de nos bâtiments sur le plan
énergétique
il consomme près de la moitié de
l'énergie consommée en france et donc si
on prête une quelconque attention aux
évolutions de la planète aux
dérèglements climatiques qui s'annoncent
et sont déjà à l'oeuvre
on doit considérer sans doute possible
que nous avons à mettre de l'ordre dans
cela alors j'entends aussi des gens me
dire mais qu'on arrête avec ses 2 degrés
qu'est ce que c'est que deux degrés dit
ces gens un peu désinvolte pensé à vous
si pendant plusieurs jours au lieu
d'avoir 37 2 le matin vous avez 39,2 ça
ira un jour 2 jours 3 jours et très vite
vous serez dans le mal être et vous
essaierez d'en sortir
mais pour la planète il faut qu on
mesure bien que 2 degrés est un de
réchauffement est un chiffre
considérable
une seule illustration quand on est
passé de la période glaciaire à la
période actuelle l'holocène devenu
l'anthropocène la différence de
température le réchauffement c'est
écoutez moi bien
4° 4° ont transformé la terre
4° ont fait en sorte que les grandes
espèces animales disparaissent ces
quatre degrés ont fait en sorte que sur
une période d'environ dix mille ans la
montée des océans a été de 130 m il ya
deux mille ans la mer noire est apparue
il ya 5000 ans mon golf du morbihan est
apparu voilà donc une réalité qui fait
que nous devons tous avoir conscience
que nos bâtiments qui représente un
mauvais score dans notre pays doivent
être l'objet de nos attentions
eh bien c'est ce qui se produit
et je vais le montrer en vous disant
quelle est la démarche assez singulière
que nous développons dans notre pays
pour mettre de l'ordre dans cet
immobilier déjà construits et à bâtir
deux volets dans la prise en compte de
la maîtrise de ses bâtiments le premier
intéresse la rénovation de ce qui existe
c'est à dire les 33 millions de
logements que nous occupons et des
surfaces dans lesquels nous exerçons nos
professions nous avons choisi le
gouvernement et la société civile que je
rassemble dans le prends plan bâtiment
durable
nous avons choisi de ne pas mettre en
oeuvre
l'obligation la coercition l'injonction
que cette transformation des bâtiments
existants
allez passer par la sollicitation de
l'intelligence des gens susciter leur
adhésion à ce projet de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et on se
contente dans les lois successives de
quelques signaux somme toute très très
simples et peu contraignants si vous
êtes co propriétaire un jour vous allez
voir venir à l'ordre du jour la
réalisation éventuelle d'un audit
énergétique de votre immeuble mais
sachez que la loi dit simplement que le
syndicat l'obligation d'inscrire seul à
l'ordre du jour mais vous pouvez décider
ce que vous voulez vous avez vu dans nos
rues apparaître dans les vitrines des
agents immobiliers
ce petit triangle coloré qui révèle le
score énergétique du bien on a
simplement dit aux agents vous devez le
m il n'a pas été prévu de sanction mais
la sanction c'est votre regard à vous
qui passait devant l' agence
il est tout à fait sûre aujourd'hui que
si vous voyez une vitrine sans ce petit
signal
vous allez dans une autre agence et puis
lorsque on a prioritairement chercher à
s'attaquer aux populations les plus
précaires
on n'a pas dit comme à l'habitude en
france voilà dz des subventions qui vous
attendent venait les chercher au guichet
non on est allé maison par maison
essayer de convaincre les ménages en
situation de précarité qu'on pouvait les
aider et on les a à domicile accompagné
dans ce processus qui permet
progressivement de sortir de cette
situation
du côté des bâtiments neufs c'est un
formidable projet qui est en ce moment
en mouvement qui va nous faire
construire bientôt des bâtiments qui à
la fois représentant un poids carbone
faible au cours de leur cycle de vie est
à la fois vont participer à la
production d'énergie renouvelable et
bien pour le faire là aussi pas de
règles pas d'obligation tout de suite
une expérimentation convient de lancer
il y a une dizaine de jours
ça veut dire que sur la base d'un
référentiel qui a été concertée entre
les professionnels et l'administration
nous lançons des labels des labels
carbone énergie qui vont permettre aux
plus entreprenant des promoteurs de se
lancer et on va prendre le temps de
regarder ce qui se passe et à partir de
retour d'expérience de calais la future
réglementation environnementale
donc il faut que vous reteniez ce
premier message dans notre pays
très jacobin très raides ou
l'administration centrale est forte on
arrive lorsqu'il y a une volonté
politique à ce que on soit intelligent
collectivement en mobilisant la société
civile mais tout cela
évidemment n'est pas fait pour le
plaisir d'avoir des bâtiments
performants ces faits pour mieux vivre
dans ces bâtiments et là on est
progressivement en train de transformer
la société
et j'espère que vous accepterez que le
mot que je viens d'employés ne vous
paraissent pas en poule et oui on va
vers une société des territoires dans
lesquels les règles pour construire
demain ne seront pas partout les mêmes
on va vers une société du partage dans
lequel à côté des immeubles qui chacun
dans son coin produiront l'énergie le
plus gros la production se fera
collectivement au plan du quartier de la
parcelle ou de la ville et nous auto
consommeront collectivement une partie
de cette énergie produite une société du
lien dans lequel les immeubles anciens
ou nouveaux seront connectés ensemble et
permettront de communiquer d'échanger
tout au cours de leur vie une société
des solidarités une société dans lequel
les usages vont être multiples une
société de la biodiversité et retenez
cette dernière idée ce qui se construit
progressivement dans la durée va
constituer une véritable transformation
de la vie des gens et favoriser le vivre
ensemble
[Applaudissements]